[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is Jonah levy I'm the CEO and
co-owner of blue whale studios in
Atlanta and I'm Matt Silva I'm also the
co-owner and the CFO of blue whale
Studios Atlanta
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but one day on set I was trying to
figure out how many individual pieces we
ran for the whole show for all seven
characters and their basketball doubles
and it came out to almost three thousand
prosthetics over the course of 35 days
[Music]
we're shooting in the summer in Atlanta
on professional athletes playing
basketball Chris Webber turned out to be
sensitive to the proper prosthetic glue
that we used to put on the pieces so we
ended up having to use something that
was water-soluble which means as soon as
he started playing basketball on those
big crazy days his makeup literally
started to melt off it got so
competitive on the court between all the
different players that in the moment
Chris literally ran across the court and
dunked and then slammed the backboard
but when he came down his neck was
literally hanging off of his face
[Music]
you